[Musique]
nous sommes au terme du cheminement
démocratique et politique de cette
réforme si vous voulez renverser le
gouvernement qu'il apporte vous en avez
désormais la possibilité je vous
remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro des grands débats
au cours de cette première année de
législature 17 motions de censure ont
été déposées par les oppositions c'est
de loin un record dans l'histoire de la
Cinquième République la motion de
censure c'est l'outil le plus puissant
dont dispose les députés dans leur
mission de contrôle du gouvernement si
elle est votée par la majorité absolue
de l'ensemble de l'hémicycle la motion
de censure contraint le Premier ministre
a présenté la démission de son
gouvernement au président de la
République nous allons revenir sur les
débats autour de ces notions ils ont
lieu dans l'hémicycle à chaque fois les
10 groupes parlementaires désignent
chacun un orateur qui monte à la tribune
pour le gouvernement c'est la première
ministre Elisabeth borne qui s'exprime
une fois que chacun a pris la parole
place au vote à noter que seuls les
députés favorables à la censure
participe au scrutin la première motion
de censure est débattue le 11 juillet
2022 un mois après les élections
législatives quelques jours plus tôt
Elisabeth borne a prononcé dans
l'hémicycle son discours de politique
générale à cette occasion elle a renoncé
à solliciter un vote de confiance des
députés la nups dépose alors cette
motion de censure en réaction au refus
de la première ministre de solliciter la
confiance les députés de gauche sont
baptisé cette motion de défiance
[Applaudissements]
il est logique que le refus de la
confiance récolte la défiance
nous voici enfin de retour en démocratie
parlementaire pour résumer vous avez été
nommé par le Président de la République
en mai puis au lendemain du naufrage des
législatives vous lui présentiez votre
démission le Président vous a maintenu
en poste et ce alors même que vos idées
sont minoritaires dans le pays vous ne
tirez donc votre légitimité ni des
élections législatives ni même du
Parlement à qui vous n'avez pas demandé
s'il vous faisait confiance pour
conduire la politique de la nation en
d'autres termes vous êtes à cette
fonction une anomalie démocratique
malheureusement aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
du quotidien des Français dont nous
parlons
le travail parlementaire vient à peine
de commencer le nouveau gouvernement est
en place depuis une semaine et certains
veulent déjà le censurer
la guerre se prolonge en Ukraine les
perspectives économiques s'assombrissent
la Russie pourrait décider de couper ses
exportations de gaz vers l'Europe les
Français ont besoin d'un gouvernement
qui agissent et certains n'ont qu'une
obsession le censurer
alors que proposez-vous un accord de
gouvernement non
des démarches constructives non une
discussion franche pour trouver des
majorités d'idées non toujours non vous
n'avez pas de majorité stable pas de
majorité
pas de majorité tout court
votre censure c'est finalement un appel
à la dissolution et bien Madame la
Présidente panneau contrairement aux
signataires de votre motion de censure
nous nous portons des solutions pas la
dissolution
le vote de confiance il est l'usage
n'est pas obligatoire et vous le savez
bien il me paraît important de rappeler
à tout le monde que Michel Rocard que
Pierre Bérégovoy qui dit de cresson mais
aussi Meurisse coude de Murville à
droite n'ont pas demandé la confiance à
l'Assemblée nationale cette notion de
censure c'était votre droit
de déposer évidemment nous ne le
contestons pas mais ce que je conteste
c'est le fait que vous ayez dit que la
première ministre était une anomalie
démocratique elle a été élue députée
vous ne pouvez pas dire le contraire et
votre candidat a été défait
Monsieur Mélenchon battu au premier tour
absent au second
invente un troisième tour qu'il perd
encore une fois et voilà que vous
proposez maintenant une motion de
censure en guise de quatrième tour il
serait peut-être temps d'admettre que
les Français ne l'ont pas élu il serait
peut-être temps de respecter la
démocratie nous sommes ici parce que
l'autoproclamé tribun du peuple je cite
ses propres termes qui ne siègent même
pas dans cette assemblée on a décidé
autrement il a exigé il vous a intime et
l'ordre madame et Messieurs les
Présidents de l'opposition de gauche que
vous transformiez nos débats en question
de procédure avec le dépôt de cette
motion il voulait même en garde vous ces
alliés politiques ils vous en coûtera
très cher de ne pas suivre ses
directives
la réalité c'est qu'en bon démocrate le
tribun du peuple n'accepte le résultat
des urnes que s'il lui est favorable
cette motion de censure au delà de vos
effets rassions aura une vertu et une
seule rappelée par votre vote
minoritaire d'aujourd'hui que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a perdu une fois encore la
présidentielle
rappelez par votre vote minoritaire
d'aujourd'hui que vous avez perdu une
fois encore les législatives
rappelez que si nous sommes en majorité
relative vous êtes vous en minorité
absolue dans cette hémistique le 16 mai
dernier madame la Première ministre vous
avez twitté je vous cite merci à
Emmanuel Macron de sa confiance et de
l'honneur qu'il me fait un moment
première ministre et vous vous êtes
présenté devant la représentation
nationale quelques jours plus tard avec
votre gouvernement de façon
permettez-moi un peu cavalière sans nous
demander la nôtre laissant ta pensée que
cela irait naturellement de soi pour
faire respecter le Parlement nous vous
n'avions donc pas d'autre choix avec nos
alliés de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale que de déposer
cette motion vous en conviendrez madame
la Première ministre nous ne pouvons pas
commencer cette législature sur un
malentendu
il faut que ce manifeste ici votre
semblant ou votre faux semblant de
légitimité puisque vous ne l'avez pas
fait il nous revient donc d'engager
votre responsabilité et la nôtre c'est
donc un acte de clarification voici venu
le temps de la clarification
cette notion permettra à chacun de se
situer et de faire apparaître une vérité
qui n'est pas utile de masquer plus
longtemps aux françaises et aux Français
il y a une opposition elle est là celle
composée par cette coalition de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale il y a une majorité relative la
vôtre madame la Première ministre il y a
aussi une majorité tacite celle que vous
formez avec les républicains il y a même
le risque d'une majorité de opportunités
que vous formerez avec le rassemblement
national
nous traversons déjà une crise sociale
économique et sécuritaire nous n'avons
pas besoin d'une crise de régime c'est
pourquoi les députés du rassemblement
national ne soutiendront pas cette
motion de censure
votre agenda idéologique et la soif de
pouvoir indécente de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
démontre que vous méprisez le peuple
vous voulez faire sauter les
institutions vous voulez l'anarchie vous
voulez l'impuissance des pouvoirs
publics et la violence de la rue vous
êtes les héritiers de cette extrême
gauche qui ne veut pas gouverner qui a
toujours détesté la Cinquième République
et qui veut la détruire paralyser la
France et nos institutions comme le
propose cette motion de censure ce n'est
pas ce que les Français attendent de
nous aujourd'hui
bien au contraire ils nous ont donné un
mandat pour agir et ils nous ont placé
dans l'obligation de dialoguer dans
l'intérêt de la France
ce n'est pas à l'heure où le Parlement
et les partis politiques ont enfin une
chance de retrouver leur légitimité et
leur place dans nos institutions et dans
l'opinion publique que nous devons nous
dérober je sais qu'à l'issue de ce débat
certains vont être tentés de délivrer
des labels d'opposition aux uns et aux
autres mais nous n'avons aucune leçon à
recevoir de qui que ce soit
nous n'avons jamais été pris en défaut
sur la force de nos convictions et sur
la crédibilité de notre positionnement
qui a été sans compromission depuis 2017
alors madame la Première ministre vous
n'avez pas notre défiance aujourd'hui
mais vous n'avez pas notre confiance
pour autant travailler dans l'intérêt
des Français et nous serons avec vous
décevez-les une nouvelle fois et nous
serons vos premiers opposants merci
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
pour être adopté cette notion de censure
a besoin de 289 voix elle en récolte 146
loin du compte si cette notion a fait le
plein chez les députés de gauche elle a
échoué à convaincre sur les autres bancs
les deuxièmes et troisième motion de
censure de cette mandature sont déposés
le 21 octobre 2022 l'assemblée est alors
en pleine examen du budget 2023 le
budget c'est le texte qui prévoit les
dépenses et les recettes de l'État c'est
quelque part la mise en musique d'un
programme politique pour cette raison
les députés de l'opposition
traditionnellement votre contre le
gouvernement sait qu'il n'a aucune
chance de faire voter le budget alors
après huit jours de débat Elisabeth
borne décide d'utiliser pour la première
fois de la mandature l'article 49-3 il
permet de faire passer le budget sans
vote mais il expose le gouvernement à
des notions de censure de sont déposés
une par le RN une par la nupes les deux
sont examinés le même jour
au cœur de l'été vous avez rappelé votre
attachement viscéral à la construction
de compromis votre peu de goût pour le
49,3 quel malaise aujourd'hui vous allez
devoir présider une assemblée muselée à
coups de 49-3 une stratégie de fin de
règne seulement 4 mois après l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron car le 49-3 c'est
l'arme des fèves l'arme de ceux qui sont
à court d'argument le 49 3 ne constitue
pas un mode apaisé apaisé et avisé de
gestion du pays ce sont l'un des
procédures qui par leur brutalité
symbolique en vocation restée
exceptionnelle le recours massif qui
promet d'y être fait témoigne non
seulement d'une faiblesse du pouvoir
mais surtout d'une incapacité à fédérer
à accepter de soumettre l'action
publique à l'écoute et à l'échange une
motion de censure ne relève pas pour
nous d'un jeu politique ni même d'une
sorte d'exercice imposé elle est pour
nous lorsque les circonstances l'exigent
l'expression solennelle et responsable
d'une défiance républicaine et
démocratique face à un pouvoir gravement
défaillant et parce que seul l'intérêt
national guide ses paroles et ses actes
le groupe que j'ai l'honneur de présidé
votre a également la motion de censure
présentée en des termes acceptables de
l'autre côté de l'hémicycle
je le dis
pour que personne
même en haut lieu ne se méprennent au
rassemblement national nous ne craignons
pas les menaces de dissolution le vent
nouveau qui s'est levé le 19 juin 2022
n'est pas près de retomber nos places ne
nous apportent pas
elle compte moins que nos convictions
moins que l'intérêt bien compris et bien
défendu des Français ce 49-3 est une
potion plus amerte que les autres elle a
pourtant le goût du 49-3 elle ressemble
à du 49.3 mais pour vous ce n'est pas du
49-3 c'est un prétendu remède pour
soigner la dangereuse irresponsabilité
des opposants c'est selon vous un 49-3
pour faire vivre la démocratie c'est
comme si vous défiliez un Lamborghini
pour sauver le climat imprégné de
l'autoritarisme d'émettre à penser du
Nouveau Monde vous renier vos
engagements loin de répondre aux
attentes de nos citoyens par une
revalorisation du Parlement et en
rééquilibrage du pouvoir vous avez
préféré interrompre les débats en
rejetant tout compromis pour satisfaire
les boulimiques de l'argent volé ceux
qui voient leurs revenus augmenter en
pleine crise ceux qui signifient la
plus-value comme de la poudre blanche
notre équilibre institutionnel est clair
il n'y a ni déni de démocratie ni
passage en force il y a d'un côté le
refus du blocage et de l'enlisement pour
donner un budget à la France et de
l'autre il y a une réponse politique ou
plutôt des réponses politiques aussi
disparaître que le sont vos groupes de
la part des oppositions
ces notions de censure c'est votre droit
et votre choix et nous verrons ce soir
par le vote souverain des députés si ces
réponses sont majoritaires ou
minoritaires
aucun aucun député de l'opposition on a
eu l'honnêteté de reconnaître que oui
oui nous avons échangé nous avons
débattu nous avons travaillé nous avons
amendé pendant près de 60 heures de
débats en hémicycle en clair nous avons
fait notre travail nous avons légiférer
[Applaudissements]
aucun député de l'opposition aucun
député de l'opposition n'a surtout dit
qu'il serait prêt à voter le budget même
si celui-ci était revu et amendé vous
avez même et tous et par anticipation
dit que vous vous opposeriez à ce budget
ne vous en déplaise l'Assemblée
nationale n'est pas la photocopieuse de
l'exécutif vous nous dites vous nous
dites que ces débats auront au moins
servi je vous cite toujours à éclairer
nos compatriotes que dire de cette
vision toute personnelle du débat
parlementaire où nous délibérons pour la
beauté du geste en macronie les députés
étudient Intex parfois jusqu'à minuit en
attendant le coup près du 49.3 pour vous
la démocratie est donc décorative cessez
de faire semblant et aller au bout de
votre idée assumez que vous souhaitez
supprimer le Parlement enfin
il vous reste à comprendre que les mots
ont un sens quand vous osez parler de
dialogue d'esprit de responsabilité
quand vous muselez en réalité la
souveraineté populaire vous ne faites
qu'achever le peu de confiance que les
Français avaient en vous les seuls
artisans du blocage c'est vous il va
falloir apprendre à gouverner autrement
il va falloir apprendre les différer
autrement voilà ce que déclarait le
président de la République alors que les
Français lui refusaient de demeurer le
président absolu qu'il avait été pendant
5 ans en lui refusant la majorité
absolue dans un contexte inédit de
fatigue démocratique dans une assemblée
sans majorité élue par moins d'un
Français sur deux et faisant surgir dans
notre hémicycle 89 députés qui n'ont pas
la République en partage avec nous
semblait se faire jour l'idée que ce
parlementarisme de fait issu des urnes
pouvait être une chance pour notre
démocratie et pour la France votre
décision n'est pas que l'application
mécanique de la Constitution ou des lois
organiques d'un parlementarisme
rationalisé que nous pourrions ne pas
même vous reprocher mais l'aveu
accablant que vous ne croyez pas à la
possibilité du compromis du débat au
pluralisme à la diversité des opinions
que vous ne tirez en définitive aucune
conséquence des résultats des élections
législatives et de votre isolement c'est
le théâtre de votre duplicité qui
s'exprime aujourd'hui au grand jour avec
vous le débat parlementaire c'est cause
toujours ou Marche à l'ombre 55
55 c'est le nombre d'heures durant
lesquelles nous avons examiné dans cette
hémicycle la première partie du projet
de loi de finance 2023 une durée déjà
supérieure au temps du débat budgétaire
de l'année dernière au cours de ces
séances nous avons discuté délibérés
jour et nuit de propositions qui émane
de tous les bancs de cette assemblée
au risque de surprendre
je veux commencer par vous dire qu'à
titre personnel j'ai trouvé les échanges
qualitatifs
certes parfois vif mais bien loin de la
formule du président Edgar fort qui
résumait les discussions budgétaires en
ces termes
litanie liturgie léthargie malgré ce
dialogue un constat s'impose à nous tous
les groupes d'opposition ont affirmé et
à maintes reprises avant même le début
de l'examen du texte leur volonté de
rejeter le budget qui leur était proposé
hélas
mes chers collègues vous le pensons au
sein de mon groupe être opposant ne se
limite pas au refus systématique et
pavloviens surtout lorsqu'elle donnait
la possibilité de composer plutôt que
d'empêcher
l'heure est donc désormais à la
responsabilité et c'est justement ce
sens des responsabilités qui a dicté à
madame la Première ministre d'avoir
recours à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution en engageant la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur cette
première partie du projet de loi de
finance il s'agit là d'un acte
nécessaire pour s'assurer la cohérence
et les résultats de l'action
gouvernementale l'engagement de la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur ces
textes et donc la suite logique il ne
faut pas mes chers collègues fermines de
son étonné ou comme l'a dit ma collègue
Mathilde Bano affirmait que cette
méthode était une brutalité et collègue
Chassaigne aussi non ce sont juste les
institutions et l'équilibre que le
roteur ont su trouver je voudrais
simplement rappeler ici ce que disait
Michel Debré le 27 août 1958 devant le
Conseil d'État qui expliquait les
raisons de la Linéa 3 de l'article 49 de
la Constitution l'expérience a conduit à
prévoir en outre une disposition quelque
peu exceptionnels pour assurer malgré
les manœuvres le vote d'un texte
indispensable les Français le savent
aucun État ne peut vivre sans un budget
qui au-delà du paiement des salaires des
fonctionnaires détermine politique et
les moyens de sa mise en œuvre vous
pouvez les uns et les autres penser que
s'opposer pour des oppositions et le
principal sujet nous considérons nous au
groupe démocrates que nous devons savoir
nous écouter et parfois douter car sans
doute il n'y a pas d'écoute
cela ne veut pas dire être toujours
d'accord mais essayez d'être constructif
et de pas rester sur des postures de
départ nous pouvons et c'est même notre
devoir devant ce pays qui est en
difficulté dialoguer construire et agir
autant que possible mesdames et
messieurs les députés deux motions de
censure ont été déposées la première
issue des rangs de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale enchaîne
les excès et les contrevérités
la nuance la complexité de certaines
questions dont il est parfois possible
de discuter en format réduit ou même en
commission ont été balayés par la
volonté d'asséner des certitudes et
quelques procès d'intention facile
je le regrette car cet été encore sans
qu'il n'y ait jamais eu de doute sur qui
était dans la majorité et qui était dans
l'opposition des voies de compromis
avaient pu émerger mais manifestement
l'insoumission a gagné la partie ne
laissant pas de place à la construction
la seconde motion de censure présentée
par le rassemblement national dissimule
mal derrière l'apparence de sérieux le
simplisme l'outrans et des fondamentaux
idéologiques qui n'ont pas bougé depuis
50 ans
alors vous le son de démocratie Madame
Le Pen je les trouve tout simplement
indécente
vous avez le mot Républic à la bouche
mais rien dans vos propos n'ont quoi que
ce soit à voir avec la République
car ce que vous visez c'est le désordre
et la discorde au prix d'une alliance
contre nature avec la nupaisse
et rassemblement national si vous avez
les uns comme les autres déposer une
motion de censure je n'imagine pas un
instant que vous pourriez gouverner
ensemble pas un instant
mais malgré cela malgré les différences
majeures que je vous connais je relève
des arguments tristement commun ce que
je retiens surtout de ces deux textes
c'est que le seul point d'accord entre
la nupesse et le rassemblement national
c'est de vouloir l'échec du gouvernement
[Musique]
au sein de la nupesse au sein de la
nupesse certaines veulent le désordre ou
plus clairement encore le chaos il
l'affirme et le revendique et le RN
prend pense tranquillement pouvoir en
récolter les fruits
[Applaudissements]
espèrent prospérer en bloquant notre
action et en misant sur l'échec du pays
la motion de censure déposée par la
nupesse obtient 239 voix malgré l'apport
des députés du rassemblement national il
en manque 50 pour qu'elle soit adoptée
de son côté la motion déposée par le
groupe RN recueille 90 voix sur
l'ensemble de la séquence budgétaire le
gouvernement a encore utilisé à 9
reprises l'article 49-3 cela engendré 11
nouvelles motions de censure 3 déposée
par la nupes deux par le rassemblement
national et 6 par la France insoumise
après l'examen du budget l'émotion de
censure sont à nouveau utilisées à deux
reprises pour un autre texte et pas des
moindres la réforme des retraites
craignant d'être battus lors du vote
dans l'hémicycle le gouvernement le 16
mars 2023 dégaine un nouveau 49-3 dans
la foulée le groupe centriste liotte et
le groupe rassemblement national dépose
chacun une motion de censure celle de
l'iott est soutenue par l'ensemble des
groupes d'opposition à l'exception des
républicains les républicains qui
apparaissent particul ièrement divisées
sur ce texte plusieurs députés ont
annoncé leur intention de voter la
censure le suspense et la tension sont
donc à leurs combles quand tu ouvres les
débats dans l'hémicycle
l'Assemblée nationale seule
représentante du peuple français n'aura
jamais voté sur ce projet de loi qui
cristallise les tensions les inquiétudes
et la colère de nos concitoyens notre
décision de déposer une motion de
censure n'a pas été prise à la légère
mais ce texte a marqué la mort des
engagements pris en juillet dernier
madame la Première ministre relire
aujourd'hui votre discours de politique
générale et cruel je vous cite nous
mènerons pour chaque sujet une
concertation dense nous aborderons
chaque texte dans un esprit de dialogue
de compromis et d'ouverture et bien vous
avez échoué à rassembler vous avez
échoué à convaincre alors vous avez cédé
à la facilité et éviter la sanction du
vote
d'autant qu'en réalité rien ne vous
oblige 49-3 le courage le respect des
institutions le respect de vos
engagements aurait dit conduire au vote
nous voulions voter même les groupes de
la majorité voulait voter ce vote vous
l'auriez très probablement perdu mais
c'est la règle en démocratie
madame la Première ministre vous avez
décidé d'engager votre responsabilité et
bien nous nous avons décidé de prendre
les nôtres avec cette notion de ceinture
ça ne veut pourquoi la réponse est
simple mais elle mérite d'être rappelée
parce que l'ego gouvernemental n'a
d'égal que la contestation qu'il
provoque contre lui cette ego il a
notamment conduit la première ministre à
utiliser 11 fois le 49-3 depuis juin
dernier sans que la brutalité ne
s'efface au profit de la lassitude
madame la première minute vous nous avez
dit jeudi dernier en annonçant votre
onzième 49.3 sur cette réforme des
retraites je vous cite ce compromis
n'est pas le projet du gouvernement
c'est le texte du Parlement mais quel
culots quel culot madame la Première
ministre
l'utilisation
l'utilisation que vous faites de la
Constitution depuis le début de cette
législature prouve que vous ne
chercherez jamais à trouver le moindre
compromis ni avec les parlementaires que
nous sommes ni avec les représentations
syndicales et encore moins avec les
Français aucune leçon depuis les gilets
jaunes n'a été retenu par l'oligarchie
en démocratie vous savez ça n'est pas
honteux de reculer face à la volonté du
peuple en déclenchant ces 49-3 c'est
précisément elle que vous tentez de
forcer mais madame la Première ministre
il est trop tard quel que soit l'issue
de ce vote ce jour vous aurez échoué
échoué à convaincre la représentation
nationale mais surtout échoué et c'est
finalement ça qui compte échouer à
convaincre les Français nous députés du
rassemblement national nous voterons
toutes l'émotion de censure car nous ne
craindrons jamais les urnes et sommes
prêts à y retourner
de sourcils des rires narquois des
injures sont au mieux ce que vous
récoltez dans le pays jamais un
président n'a voulu gouverner avec
autant d'aplombs par la colère et le
dégoût à présent deux Français sur trois
veulent que cette motion de censure
aboutissent pour faire chuter le
gouvernement et votre réforme les
Français avaient pourtant joué le jeu
avec des syndicats Unis il manifestaient
pacifiquement depuis des semaines
faisait grève perdez des jours de
salaire au moment même où les prix
explosent avec ce 49-3 Emmanuel Macron
souffle à l'oreille du pays un
raisonnement dangereux en démocratie
pour être entendu la démocratie ne
suffit plus que reste-t-il alors le
forcené de l'Élysée et des goupilles une
grenaille et bouge toutes les issues il
ne laisse au peuple aucune porte de
sortie il porte l'entière responsabilité
d'une explosion de colère la période a
révélé aux yeux de tous une réalité pas
été insoutenable vous ne servez à rien
oui vous ne servez à rien si ce n'est
nuire quand les éboueurs font grève du
jour le paysage et les odeurs s'en
trouvent changer si votre gouvernement
tombait ce soir les Français seraient
simplement soulagés
madame la Première ministre
vous ne pouvez rien face à ceux qui font
tout peu importe l'issue de cette motion
de censure vous avez déjà perdu pour
beaucoup votre gouvernement est déjà
mort au moment où vous passiez en force
par arrogance votre pouvoir s'est
effondré les noms de bornes du soft et
autres m'inspirent français ko Le cœur
le désir de battre Emmanuel Macron et sa
réforme est devenue contagieuse même
l'empereur Caligula a été vaincu c'était
après s'être regardée dans le miroir
merci de ton Emmanuel Macron contemple
son reflet il y verra bientôt sa chute
merci beaucoup
j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de venir à cette
tribune sans ce qui devrait être tous
nous réunir à savoir notre Constitution
et oui et oui je ne crois pas que cela
prête à rire
notre Constitution parce qu'elle est en
fait le bien commun qui doit réunir les
parlementaires oui une motion de censure
défecto devient un programme commun
parce qu'une motion de censure c'est la
capacité à trouver une alternative
crédible à dégager une autre majorité et
donc en fonction de celles ou ceux qui
voteront ensemble cette motion de
censure qui s'applaudiront ensemble pour
le vote de cette motion de censure alors
vous direz aux Français quelle est
prétendument la majorité alternative
alors vous direz aux Français quel est
prétendument le gouvernement alternatif
avec Charles de Courson en premier
ministre avec Marine Le Pen à Bercy avec
Mathilde panot un ministre de
l'Intérieur et avec un empanité Aurélien
Pradier ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement c'est ça le projet alternatif
que vous soumettez il y a la solidité de
qui ont défendu et qui ont porté ce
projet essentiel pour nos compétriotes
d'abord le ministre du Travail que vous
n'avez eu de cesse d'invectiver
d'insulter de piétiner au sens figuré
mais en vérité finalement vous aviez
envie de le faire au sens propre oui
Olivier du socle avec Gabriel Attal on
portait avec courage le projet qui est
aujourd'hui soumis à vos votes nous
assumons de défendre ce texte parce que
oui sans cette réforme à la fin en
disant nous aurons accumulé 150
milliards de déficit la vérité elle est
là et vous ne pouvez pas la contester la
vérité c'est que oui la justice est
d'abord de faire en sorte que cette
réforme soit adoptée parce que ceux qui
vont trinquer ceux qui trinqueraient en
premier ce sont les plus fragiles de
notre pays qui eux n'ont que la
solidarité intergénérationnelle pour
faire en sorte d'espérer un jour avoir
le droit à une retraite
j'habite tous ceux qui qualifient ici à
tel processus de votre dictatorial à
ôter leur filtre idéologique et prendre
un peu de recul depuis le début de
l'examen de ce projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale comme depuis le début de la
législature le gouvernement s'est
conformé à la règle de droit en premier
lieu la Constitution
que l'utilisation des outils du
parlementarisme rationalisé déplaise aux
oppositions c'est finalement assez
logique et je n'entends parfaitement je
vous rassure personne je dis bien
personne ne se réjouit du recours à cet
article 49 alinéa 3 parmi les
parlementaires ici présents qui sont
tout aussi attachés que vous à la
préservation des prérogatifs du
Parlement mais dire que cela constitue
un déni de démocratie ou une atteinte au
droit du Parlement après 175 heures de
débat est quasiment autant d'obstruction
nous ne pouvons pas l'entendre notre
mandat électif nous oblige vis-à-vis des
Français la première de ces obligations
c'est agir en responsabilité et d'être
responsable en ce jour c'est rappeler
qu'un pays surendetté ne peut pas
financer son avenir prétendre l'inverse
c'est notamment mentir à notre jeunesse
qui aura assumé les conséquences de nos
choix oui nous avons des regrets
notre premier regret celui n'avoir
jamais pu pleinement examiner et voter
ce texte en première lecture alors que
les deux semaines prévues suffisait à le
faire chers collègues de l'opposition en
dépit des règles de fair-play
parlementaire et plus encore de toute
vertu démocratique vous avez décidé de
détourner notre règlement pour créer une
embolie parlementaire nous voulions très
majoritairement groupe démocrate modem
et indépendant allez au vote de ce texte
après peut-être pour certaines et
certains des doutes mais surtout avec la
conviction que cette loi a été
nécessaire et utile
nous prenons un de la décision qui a été
prise le déclencher la procédure prévue
par la Linéa 3 de l'article 49 de notre
Constitution cet outil existe il permet
aux forces politiques qui sont contre ce
texte de le rejeter si elles sont
majoritaires
quoi qu'il en coûte à la démocratie la
réforme des retraites voulue par le
président de la République est un coup
de force politique elle n'est pas
seulement un impôt sur la vie de celles
et de ceux qui n'ont que leurs forces de
travail pour vivre elle symbolise comme
jamais sa pratique solitaire du pouvoir
qui pervertit la démocratie rend
possible son retournement en son
contraire impose ces volontés sans
discussion avec arrogance et mépris
mépris du débat parlementaire et du
dialogue social
mépris de la mobilisation syndicale et
de la volonté populaire mépris de
l'opposition majoritaire dès lors que
comme vous l'avez concédé vous-même le
compte n'est pas vous soutenez le
mensonge d'une réforme de compromis
alors que vous n'avez dialogué en
sincérité avec personne ne vous êtes
accordé avec personne n'avait convaincu
personne quoi qu'il en coûte à la
démocratie le président se comporte
aujourd'hui en forcené en acharné en
former désormais dans un tête-à-tête
avec lui-même
ce n'est pas du courage c'est de l'arrêt
des raisons retirer cette réforme il en
coûtera moins que votre obstination car
il en va désormais de l'intérêt général
de la concorde civile de l'avenir de
notre démocratie quand tout s'écroule je
vous l'assure pour tenir debout il faut
bien plus qu'une paire de bottes je dis
16 mars 2023 constitue un point de
rupture la rupture entre un président et
tout un peuple la rupture entre un
président de la République qui a
théorisé la société des premiers de
cordée et tout un peuple qui depuis
qu'il a fait la Révolution en 1789
recherche constamment obstinément
passionnément la réalisation de la
promesse républicaine de l'égalité
c'est au nom de l'égalité que les
Français se lèvent contre votre réforme
ne l'ignorez pas ne le maîtrisez pas ne
méprisez pas ces millions de personnes
qui ont défilé et qui défileront demain
encore soutenues par tout un pays ne
fermez pas les yeux à la vue des
pancartes qui fleurissent un peu partout
en France et qui tombe bien que mal
tente de vous faire entendre raison
alors pendant quelques instants je vais
me faire le porte-voix de ce que vous
avez décidé d'ignorer il chante avec
Macron liberté égalité retraite mais
quand vous serez décédé il chante encore
les précaires prêtres précaires ce n'est
pas un métier ou encore les profits des
milliardaires pour les vieux jours de
nos grands-mères et cela doit vous
rappeler d'autres mobilisations celles
des ronds-points des gilets jaunes du
ras-le-bol des travailleuses pauvres
souvenez-vous elles écrivaient alors
taxons d'abord le kérosène gilets jaunes
vs parachute doré la France d'en bas
contre la France dans haut le président
n'a pas perdu le contact avec les
Français de il ne les a jamais croisés
depuis les bancs de ces écoles privées
jusqu'à son fauteuil dans des dans des
banques d'affaires il ne les a jamais
croisés alors ils pensent qu'il peut
marchander des trimestres en dans leur
dos
ils pensent qu'il peut maintenir un âge
de départ à la retraite qui rend
inopérant le principe des annuités qui
protégeait ceux qui ont des Callies
longues et pourtant un travailleur qui a
mis les mains dans le cambouis des 18
ans vous le savez je le sais à une
espérance de vie bien moins élevée que
ceux de la plupart d'entre nous un grand
renfort d'éléments de langage vous nous
rappelez que oui vous nous piétinez mais
en toute légalité mais voilà ce qui est
légal n'est pas forcément légitime vous
auriez tort de ne pas vous soucier
d'adosser vos actions à la légitimité
populaire une élection présidentielle à
fortiori celle de 2022 n'est pas un
blanc sain à gouverner et à réformer
contre 75% des Français madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers et chers collègues
une colère
pas un coup de colère
encore moins une vague de désapprobation
une profondeur
quelque chose dans l'ordre de la révolte
même le refus sans appel de la
régression sociale le refus de se voir
voler d'eau de ses meilleures années de
retraite le sentiment de ne jamais
pouvoir être entendu le sentiment d'être
pris pour des imbéciles le sentiment de
ne pas être respecté l'idée que ça
suffit tout simplement je me demande
comment vous pouvez être encore là à
défendre votre réforme scélérate qui n'a
pas de majorité dans cette assemblée qui
en a encore moins dans le pays votre
réforme est définitivement illégitime et
vous vous trompez lourdement si vous
pensez que vous pouvez vous en tirer
comme ça que c'était juste un mauvais
moment à passer que tout ça sera bientôt
oublié ce n'est pas le caprice d'un
enfant à la caisse du supermarché votre
projet est grillé vous avez perdu la
bataille des retraites dans quelques
minutes si 287 d'entre nous le décident
la volonté de deux tiers des Français et
de renvoyer ce gouvernement et son in je
te réforme des retraites peut devenir
une réalité en République il n'y a qu'un
seul souverain c'est le peuple tout
entier et non pas le président de la
République enfermé dans son palais c'est
en fait une crise de régime les liens
spasmes de la lampe agonie de cette
cinquième république des sens
monarchique à bout de souffle deux tiers
des Français souhaite l'adoption de
cette motion de censure deux tiers des
Français souhaite votre départ madame la
Première ministre deux tiers des
Français souhaite que le mouvement
contre la réforme des retraites se
poursuivre mais parce que sous les
lustres dorés des plafonds de l'Elysée
un homme seul et toujours plus isolé
souhaite rhabiller un passage en force
en processus démocratique ce sont deux
tiers des Français qui devraient être
censurés
des champs des hurlements des invectives
des pupitres qui claquent voilà le
spectacle auquel se sont livrés jeudi
dernier certains députés
dans un déchaînement de violence comme
cette émission en a peu connu sous la
Cinquième République
certains élus de la nation ont une
nouvelle fois montré le peu de cas qu'il
faisait du débat du Parlement de la
démocratie
ce sont des élus de la nation qui
viennent nous expliquer sans vergogne
que 175 heures de séances plus que pour
les deux précédentes réforme des
retraites ne valent rien ce sont des
députés qui déni son rôle au Parlement
et affirme que la rue est plus légitime
que les institutions
aujourd'hui c'est sur votre texte pas
sur le projet du gouvernement mais bien
sur le compromis trouvé par le Parlement
que j'engage ma responsabilité
[Applaudissements]
rejetez ce compromis ce serait financé
nos retraites par la dette et fragilisée
dangereusement notre système par
répartition quand je vois une motion de
censure signée par toute la gauche mais
avec comme figure de proue un partisan
de la retraite à 64 ans comme le
proposait monsieur le député de Courson
votre amendement en octobre 2013
attenant historique de l'austérité
budgétaire un opposant notoire au
mariage pour tous et qui n'a pas voté
l'inscription de l'abolition de la peine
de mort dans la Constitution
alors je constate alors je constate que
la nups
quand elle est prête à toutes les
compromissions quand il s'agit de
chercher le blocage
le 49,3 n'est pas l'invention d'un
dictateur mais le choix profondément
démocrate qu'a fait le général de Gaulle
et qui a approuvé le peuple français car
à la fin il y a un vote nous sommes au
terme du cheminement démocratique et
politique de cette réforme si vous
voulez renverser le gouvernement qui la
porte vous en avez désormais la
possibilité je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
à ce moment de l'année parlementaire il
faut 287 voix pour que la motion de
censure du groupe IOT soit adoptée elle
en recueille
278 il aura donc manqué 9 députés pour
faire tomber le gouvernement et avec lui
sa réforme des retraites de son côté la
motion de censure du rassemblement
national recueille 94 voix malgré cette
échec les groupes d'opposition veulent
maintenir la question des retraites à
l'agenda parlementaire alors le groupe
centriste liotte dépose cette fois une
proposition de loi pour revenir sur la
modification de l'âge de départ en
retraite désormais fixé à 64 ans mais
lors de l'examen dans l'hémicycle la
présidente de l'Assemblée Yaël Brom
Pivet déclare ce texte irrecevable d'un
point de vue financier elle s'appuie sur
l'article 40 de la Constitution le
groupe iode décide alors de retirer sa
proposition de loi furieux contre ce
qu'il considère comme un nouvel acte
antidémocratique les députés de la
nupesse déposent une nouvelle motion de
censure c'est la dernière en date de
cette mandature
madame la Première ministre
permettez-moi de vous rappeler que sous
la Cinquième République
c'est vous qui êtes responsable devant
l'Assemblée nationale c'est vous qui
devez rendre compte au Parlement et pas
le contraire
jetez le discrédit sur l'Assemblée
nationale c'est aussi avoir empêché le
débat sur la proposition de loi
d'abrogation de votre réforme des
retraites il n'est de secret pour
personne que le gouvernement a fait
pression sur la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale pour que ce débat
n'est pas lieu cette décision est un
très grave précédent censuré le
gouvernement est un acte grave et je le
mesure pleinement
mais laissez perdurer
mais laissez perdurer le discrédit sur
notre assemblée par le gouvernement
marquerait un renoncement de notre part
plus grave encore c'est pour cela que
j'invite chacune et chacun d'entre vous
a voté cette motion de censure pour la
17e fois en moins d'un an une motion de
censure est déposée contre mon
gouvernement
je voulais commencer par un mot qui
surprendra peut-être
merci
merci madame la Présidente de montrer
une nouvelle fois par cette motion de
censure que nous sommes bel et bien dans
une démocratie parlementaire où le
gouvernement est responsable devant le
Parlement qui peut à tout moment tenter
de le renverser
mesdames et messieurs les députés s'en
sort pourtant il n'y a pas les bons
articles de la Constitution quand vous
les invoquez et les mauvaises articles
de la Constitution quand nous les
invoquons la Constitution n'est pas un
géométrie variable on ne prend pas les
articles qui nous plaisent avant de
rejeter ce qui ne nous arrange pas la
Constitution est un bloc et quand on
respecte la République on l'accepte en
entier du début à la fin des et
messieurs les députés
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez s'il vous plaît
vous taire et écouter la première minute
vous ne l'interrompre vous ne cessez de
l'interrompre monsieur Boyard monsieur
Boyard je vous demande de vous taire
monsieur Boyard monsieur Boyard je vous
rappelle alors
monsieur Boyard
je prononce à votre rencontre un appel à
l'ordre avec inscription au
procès-verbal
je vous prie de vous taire et de
respecter cet assemblée la première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les députés
mesdames et messieurs les députés bien
sûr les comparaisons doivent se manier
avec prudence et je ne m'y risquerais
pas mais chacun mesure que nous
traversons l'une de ces périodes où les
défis sont multiples les bascules
nombreuses et les changements se
précipitent certains semblent avoir du
mal avec les règles de nos institutions
et refusent de reconnaître leurs
défaites quitte à mentir à nos
concitoyens mentir car personne sur ses
bancs ne pouvait ignorer que cette
proposition de loi aurait créé une
charge supplémentaire pour les finances
publiques de notre pays l'intangibilité
de la réalité la voici vous protestez
nous respectons la lettre des textes qui
régissent la Cinquième République c'est
aussi simple que ça l'ensemble des
procédures parlementaires prévues ont
été respectées du début à la fin et vous
le contestez parce que le résultat n'est
pas conforme à vos attentes ni qui le
président ne vous comportait en garant
des institutions vous vous comportez en
propriétaire vous considérez que nos
institutions sont au service de votre
idéologie de votre programme vous êtes
persuadé des tenir la périté mais vous
ne faites plus de la politique vous êtes
partis en croisade vous voulez faire
prospérer coûte que coûte un modèle
capitaliste contre les communs contre
les Français condamnant leur présence et
leur futur cette notion de censure et
bien plus que l'expression d'un
désaccord elle est désormais la seule
option qui nous est offerte par une
constitution au service quasi exclusif
du pouvoir exécutif pour tenter de
mettre un terme à l'autoritarisme de
votre pouvoir
en macronie le président la plus mal élu
de la 5e République impose seul contre
tout un peuple 2 ans de vie volée en
macronie une loi peut passer en force
sans aucune légitimité parlementaire ni
légitimité populaire en macronie
l'Assemblée nationale est piétinée
l'initiative parlementaire et le droit
d'amendement bafoué en macronie les
citoyens l'Inter syndical les
associations les représentants du peuple
ne comptent pour rien seule valent les
caprices du président auquel la Nation
toute entière doit se plier madame la
Première ministre vous avez bouché
toutes les issues démocratiques vous ne
vous rendez même plus compte des seuils
que vous franchissez gouverner c'est
assumer une responsabilité devant
l'histoire avec vos méthodes vous ouvrez
la porte du pire
le bras de fer d'Emmanuel Macron contre
le peuple de France et tout le contraire
de la démocratie pourquoi avez-vous peur
de débattre pourquoi avez-vous peur du
Parlement pourquoi avez-vous peur de
voter et faire voter pourquoi avez-vous
peur du peuple pourquoi avez-vous peur
des Français tout simplement
pourtant vous n'hésitez jamais à asséner
que vous avez été lu par eux que votre
mandat est issu d'une majorité somme
toute relative du peuple votant pourtant
vous tremblez vous tremblez comme des
feuilles mortes d'un sombre matin
d'automne
vous bafouez les droits les plus
élémentaires du parlementarisme en
musulmans les oppositions et a priori ça
vous fait sourire le respect des
oppositions parlons-en tout en souriant
et n'écoutant pas outre le fait de
garantir la vie démocratique permet
aussi de légiférer dans un climatisé en
essayant de bâtir des compromis au nom
de la nation au nom du peuple ne restez
pas une nouvelle fois spectateur de
l'histoire et surtout complice de la
minorité présentielle ayez la France au
cœur ne soyez pas une nouvelle fois la
béquille d'un gouvernement éculé la
béquille d'un gouvernement qui mène
notre démocratie à genoux le groupe
rassemblement national fort de sa ligne
de conduite inchangée dont j'ai
l'honneur de porter la voix et la parole
aujourd'hui prendra lui une nouvelle
fois ses responsabilités et votera au
nom du peuple qui a mis ce gouvernement
en minorité la motion de censure qui
nous occupe il est fondamental urgent
de censurer ce gouvernement méprisant et
arrogant qui en seulement 9 mois a déjà
piétiné le peuple et notre assemblée à
de multiples reprises et se croient
toujours un touchable mes chers
collègues nous ne redresserons la France
qu'avec la confiance des Français voilà
pourquoi nous ne devons pas avoir peur
de la menace de dissolution car c'est au
peuple français de trancher le conflit
légitimité entre un président isolé et
une assemblée de moins en moins
gouvernable nous pensons madame la
Première ministre que vous devriez tirer
vous-même les conclusions qui s'imposent
vont votre responsabilité désormais
serait de démissionner madame la
Première ministre
c'est le meilleur service que vous
pourriez rendre à notre pays il ne
s'agit pas là d'une attaque personnelle
mais vous êtes clairement identifié
maintenant comme la représentante d'un
système technocratique et de
concentration des pouvoirs qui
s'imaginent que l'on peut gouverner sans
le Parlement sans les corps
intermédiaires et sans le peuple votre
démission démontrerait que vous auriez
compris le caractère indispensable d'une
nouvelle gouvernance de nouvelles
méthodes de décision d'un nouveau mode
de gouvernement plus démocratique la clé
de réussite pour notre pays aujourd'hui
cette motion de censure qui n'a aucune
chance d'être adopté ne vise qu'à
prolonger artificiellement un combat
perdu à maintenir l'agitation dans la
rue et à transformer la démocratie en
oncocratie
lorsque votre guide suprême Monsieur
Mélenchon lorsqu'il faut mettre bas la
mauvaise République c'est un bras
d'honneur à l'ordre républicain
rien d'étonnant de la part de ceux qui
préfèrent les casseurs de sainte Soline
au gendarmes blessés et les Vandales du
soulèvement de la terre au labeur
patient de nos paysans
tout cela pourquoi pour assister au
mariage de la carpe et les filles et du
lapin RN alliés objectifs de la
politique de la terre brûlée notre
groupe ne prêtera pas la main à la
manœuvre politicienne qui nous occupe
car notre famille politique est celle de
l'ordre de la liberté et du progrès 16
c'est le nombre de motions de censure
examinées depuis juin 2022 autant
d'occasions peut la représentation
nationale d'affirmer encore et encore
son soutien au gouvernement d'Elizabeth
borne car rappelons tout ont été rejetés
autant d'échecs pour l'extrême droite
comme pour l'extrême gauche qui malgré
leur volonté de faire oeuvre commune ne
parviennent pas à constituer une
majorité alternative
celle-ci la 17e ne fera pas exception
elle sera rejetée
à ceux qui ont lancé cette motion jeudi
vos tentatives pour déstabiliser le
gouvernement ne font que renforcer notre
détermination à servir le peuple
français vos tactiques politiques ne
font qu'accentuer l'importance de notre
travail et le besoin de rester concentré
sur nos missions ce gouvernement a fait
preuve de résilience face à de très
nombreux défis je salue à cet égard la
solidité et la détermination de notre
première ministre le texte rappelle en
hors-d'oeuvre l'utilisation par le
gouvernement mais dans des conditions
vont en parfaitement régulières et jugés
comme tel par le Conseil constitutionnel
de divers articles de la Constitution
qui n'ont pas l'heure de plaire aux
oppositions mais ce que ce texte met
vraiment en cause ce sont les points de
procédure qui ont conduit à l'échec
jeudi dernier de l'initiative du gros
pilote le problème c'est que sur les
points litigieux ce n'est pas le
gouvernement
mais le Parlement et plus précisément
l'Assemblée nationale
son bureau c'est commissions le
président de la commission des finances
est bien entendu
la présidence de notre assemblée qui est
en cause et qui devrait être blâmé si
tenter qu'il y ait matière à blâme la
censure n'est pourtant pas un fusil
attiré dans les coins vous avez le
perchoir dans la lunette et vous tirez
sur le banc drôle de chasseurs en vérité
avec vous la galinette cendrée ne peut
recevoir qu'une balle perdue
239 voix c'est le score obtenu par cette
notion de censure encore une fois c'est
insuffisant pour être adopté et faire
tomber le gouvernement les 17 motions de
censure déposées au cours de cette
première année de mandature ont donc
toutes été rejetées le gouvernement bien
qu'en majorité relative dans l'hémicycle
a donc pour l'instant suffisamment de
soutien à l'Assemblée pour faire passer
ces réformes sans tomber sous le coup
près d'émotions de censure c'est la fin
de ce numéro des grands débats merci de
l'avoir suivi et à bientôt sur LCP
[Musique]